[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter dati
super content avec dom plan cette
semaine au podcast en a reçu marianne
st-gelais athlètes olympiques patineuse
courte piste qui est allé trois fois aux
jeux d'hiver été championne du monde
on a parlé de toute sa carrière on est
revenus là dessus ces moments forts ces
moments plus difficiles des menaces de
mort qu'à leur succès que le contre
performé jeu régime et ses rangs pas
drôle non et maintenant les retraités
depuis depuis un an alors où en est sa
vie qu'est-ce qu'il fait maintenant
débat conversation même parler des cross
fit belle rencontre une personne et une
énergie débordante les come on come on
voit rarement quand même l'énergie
vraiment incroyable qui est super drôle
super gentil alors un une belle
rencontre
on a parlé de sa fierté de devenir du
lac la fierté du lac
si vous aimez sans fil podcast on a une
plateforme peinture non le dis à chaque
fois mais c'est parce qu'à chaque pays
du monde continuent à venir n'ont
rejoint il rejoint notre communauté là
bas donc on s'inscrit on nous encourage
pas on a accès à du contenu exclusif ont
accès aux podcasts en avance on peut
imposer des questions aux invités
donc allez voir ce lien va être dans la
description de cette vidéo si sinon
abonnez-vous à la chaîne sans fil du
podcast pour être à l'affût de tous les
podcasts qui vont continuer à sortir à
chaque semaine la fuite ou les vidéos
qu'on va mettre en ligne et commenté par
participer à la discussion
parlez-en à vos amis vous chargez c'est
le meilleur tous ont pas de 4,6 à lui
[Musique]
mariam salut salut salut salut d'être là
c'est un honneur de recevoir aussi on
arrête ce succès n'est déjà on avait
reçus
roseline filion ce que je dis en entrée
de discussion c'était pour quelqu'un qui
fait du sport comme comme nous le niveau
que des personnes comme toi ou des
personnes comme roselyne ont atteint on
ne plus la compréhension de ce que ça
prend pour ça représente pour ça se
rende le capteur monsieur madame tout le
monde qui cotait olympique
il voit pas nécessairement le chemin
s'apprend et prennent un peu pour acquis
les athlètes canadiens 18 heures mais
lui et il est bon il est juste bon mais
si c'est d'autant plus impressionnant
quand c'est le chemin que ça a quelque
fois ci la fine pointe
c'est le point à 1 01 % des gens qui
réussissent à ce rang bleu puis à faire
ce bravo pour hubert l'ensemble de ton
est alors vous avez raison mais plus on
est sportif l'autre tu fais du sport
parce qu'au départ thème c'est une
passion le ti après son oui ça peut
t'amener à les olympiques à des rails va
tout ça mais mais au delà je pense qu'il
faut ramener ça à la base aussi le titre
moi c'est pour ça que je me trouve pas
plus haut de gamme et 11 autres qui
ouais j'ai des médailles mais en bout de
ligne si tu enlèves les ménages aient
fait les mêmes sacrifices que vous avez
fait même si c'est pour faire il ajouté
le sport non mais c'est moi je trouve
comme un essai comme ok on se fait super
genre ah mais si j'ai travaillé aussi
fort que les 18 filles avec qui je
m'entraîne et aux candidats
mais en bout de ligne on est tellement
beaucoup de sélectionnés peu d'élus
mais ça n'enlève pas le fait que les
gens en général sportif travail
excessivement je réfléchissais justement
à quel point en sport il est tellement
plus de déçus que de contenter une
compétition c'est rare en plus que
quelqu'un qui contente tout ça est
arrivé premier souvent deuxième puis
troisième devrait être comptables sont
déçus quant à manu mais c'est ça marche
plus loin par année c'est comme
importantes jusqu'à demain
plus belle que c'est moins sûr le
résultat plus sûrs maintenant la
démarche l'ascension le processus parce
que sinon manette et je députés juste
plus jamais contente car ce compte pas
améliorer son tour d'améliorer 4 qui
marque un casque c'est quoi la prochaine
affaire qui a pris une médaille vous
avez pu que c'est quoi la prochaine
chose qui peut te me satisfaire le real
au champion du monde mais c'est encore
le step ah ben oui y'a quoi que je suis
gamin je fais comment comment tu reste
motivé au stade a une longue carrière
m'intéresse motivé à travers toutes ces
imagine que c'est beau succès là
j'imagine qu'il faut que c'est sur sa
propre personne veut dépasser plutôt que
sur steam et ya au moins bon que l'autre
imagine que ça fait partie de la clé
j'imagine succès lupi du de profiter de
des parcours lot oui justement l'accord
puis moi je trouve que ma carrière j'ai
eu des bosquets protéger pas passé de
zéro à airolo ti ça a vraiment été
progressif petit championnat très zen
non au thé mais des filles ont été
réalistes d'année en année utile j'ai
beau sauter d'étapes de rien mais en
même temps je pense que j'ai quand même
dû m'ajuster parce que j'ai fait les
olympiques à 19 ans j'avais demandé un
épais qu'un vin et en fait quand même
emmené ma carrière était jeune encore
sept à 10 premiers jeux à ce moment là
je savais pas combien de la frc mais il
risque j'ai dû quand même ajusté au
courant de ma carrière tu fais parce
qu'il ya un moment dans ma vie où je
parlais avec mon préparateur mental que
je me disais dans le fond moi je suis
jamais satisfait mais claude à un
problème parce que c'est moi j'ai envie
d'aimer ce que je fais mais j'ai
l'impression que je serai plus jamais
satisfaite parce qu'il faut que je gagne
si je gagne c'est normal que je donne à
l'excellence exact que je sais comme moi
ça ça puisse pas possible si je peux pas
aller le fait que j'ai dû apprendre à en
fait à laisser aller un peu les
résultats sont les acteurs dont veut
tout gagner ou perdre 500 roses en
équipe qui dans une préparation puis tu
fais comme moi je dois finir deuxième
pourtant cette passé n'ont cessé c'est
réglé c'est ce que j'allais vouloir
gagner c'est pour les sportifs les
athlètes d'excellence aux autres
l'important c'est pas n'existe pas une
participation effective à donner un
ruban participation le site avec ce
tacle à gaza mais maintenant oui le truc
en partie mais non les positions compost
tombe pas sur les faits ces bons même
année
en même temps c'est ça qui drive c'est
moi je voulais moi 7 phone puis ma
passion qui me drive et puis qui me fait
gagner si toi c'est ton attitude de
guerrier mais ça va être sorti
moi je les ramener à ça j'ai ramené à sa
plus simple expression system qu'est ce
qui te vas te faire gagner mais c'est le
processus puis moi je vais être fier de
mes courses je vais être heureuse et
épanouie bon fait que ça va gagner ça me
fait gagner ça fait venir quatrième ça
va être 4e parce que crime
les filles étaient meilleurs que moi
mais moi j'ai donné ce que j'avais à
donner ça a été un peu de réorganiser
puis de revoir un peu ma stratégie parce
que le j'avais plaisir puimoisson le fun
que j'avais dans mon sport
quand tu sais que tu te fait que tu
pouvais faire pour faire une apparence
possible à m'emmener mais le tir est
salie c'est ce qu'est ce que je peux
faire des plus riches en gt moqueur
georges et que j'arrive mettons
troisième ou 20e
j'ai fait un bep stijm j'étais content
mais pis c'est là aussi tu le dis le
ramène ça toi tu en as tendance à
tellement se comparer puis à dire à lui
merkel - lui est fait est fait sur moi
mais là le rouge
c'est vous qui compare à toi c'est toi
qu'est-ce que tu es capable de donner
effectué peu déçu mais tu peux pas être
déçu parce que les autres ont fait
meilleur tu peux être déçu parce que toi
t'as pas fait
mettons qu'est-ce que tu devais faire
mais en bout de ligne ça te fait tout ce
que devrait faire m pas être des succès
mais où tout peut être déçu mais c'est
tellement plus facile à procès cible
c'est tellement plus facile à accepter
quand tu dis mais qu'est ce que je
ferais de différents absolument est bon
mais c'est avant mais cela parce que je
n'aime pas ça le choses qui me fascine
dans le patinage de vitesse courte piste
puis c'est pourrait rebondir un peu sur
ce qu'on dit le team est on si je
combats de la natation la natation
si tu fais ta performance tu vas avoir
exactement le temps que toi tu vas avoir
fait sans aucun
les autres ont pas d incidence aucune
600 personnes qui vient qui vient jouer
avec ce mais admettons que c'est
difficile de dire
j'ai donné mon 100 pour cent
dans une course où est ce que pour j'ai
l'impression une erreur stratégique
notre facteur externe
il finit pas comme comme torres ou été
tués c'est difficile d'évaluer en
natation du tout chômeur c'est quand
même qu'ils aient donné 100% je valais
deux minutes aux 200 kroll aujourd'hui
pas plus que je souhaitais à la dation
en train demande de me donner mais
c'était difficile mais ton de gi joe
quel niveau de toi même tes parce que si
jamais les mêmes personnes autour de toi
si jamais la même course si jamais la
même
la même affaire mais comment est-ce
qu'on établit justement tombe ton niveau
envers toi - ben on gère qu'est-ce qu'on
peut gérer
oui parce que tu le dis a tellement
d'impondérables dans notre sport
tellement de choses qu'on peut pas
contrôler que si on essaye de les
contrôler on essaie de tout gérer ça me
repose pas c est qu on n'a pas le choix
d'avoir un espèce de laisser aller là
dessus sur j'ai pas le contrôle sur tout
ce qui va arriver mais ce que je peux
contrôler je vais le contrôler à 100%
parce qu'en bout de ligne je ne sais pas
ça va être quoi la fin de cette course
noté péter vivent pas un facteur chance
aussi dans notre poule c est juste
heureux dit sur les adversaires tino
vagues sont sont décidés selon les temps
sont les positions fait peu
avoir une super séries finals comme
lauda côté peut avoir quelque chose qui
ressort on peut pas contrôler après ça
il ya tellement je veux dire dans les
courses des chutes la glace est
tellement de choses qu'on peut pas
savoir en fait six ou sept secondes
vraiment se concentrer sur ce qu'on peut
gérer
malheureusement c'est ça le sport est
inscrit bain puis on a une forte
capacité aussi datation une forte
capacité de se retourner puis de
justement de laisser aller ces choses là
parce que sinon nos distances on a
plusieurs du temps sont nos penseurs
chose à faire en fait d'une longue
distance à faire d'un peu comme en
natation fax y planta première bien il
faut que tu te ramène pourquoi je vais
revenir les compétitions sont longues
sont plusieurs jours de plusieurs
chances de plusieurs épreuves les
épreuves cd x 2 m en natation tain c'est
1,50 kroll [ __ ] 1500 kg alors que ça
va dans des zones énergétique
complètement différent en patinage
courte piste
j'ai pas l'impression que tu navigues
tensions entre les ondes énergétique la
raison où notre plus longue distance
olympique c'est un quinze 100 m dont 13
tours et demi puis notre plus courtes c1
500 m dont quatre tours et demi avec
mais en bout de ligne
l'effort est semblable que je dire ce
que les preuves qui beaucoup plus sprint
que l'autre mais je vois contraint
marins ça se ressent est ce que la
plupart des gens ont des niveaux plutôt
égal à chacune des courses ou bien
vraiment imaginer spécialisés quand même
les distances que moi ça fonctionne
comme une spécialisation le ses succès
comme moi je t'aime sprinteuse mais il
reste pour un titre de championne du
monde pour un titre olympique il faut
quand même que tu sois complet il faut
que ça bien débrouillé sur toutes les
distances fait c'est certain que si on
fait une rétrospective de toute ma
carrière mes meilleurs résultats restent
au 500 m mais sur quinze 100 m jeudi
très bons résultats aussi même scénario
sur 1000 m
on approchait d'un peu polyvalent c'est
bien en temps d'entraînement fait ça
aussi c'est une question se spécialiser
en entraînement c'est à dire qu'on avait
vraiment une focus seulement sur l'a5
ça m'aide pour marianne à l'entraînement
peut-être que je consomme est devenu
beaucoup trop spécifique l'entraînement
qu'on fait en groupe on a affaire à des
filles qui sont très très peu de cardio
un super vo2 fx a fait que maintenant on
se regroupe ensemble pour notre choix de
faire la job fait que ça nous permet de
rester pas mal et ça c'est important
parce que c'est comme cumulatif comment
ça fonctionne et ce qui t'as besoin
pourquoi tu as besoin d'être bonnes à
plusieurs épreuves pour le championnat
du monde cumulatif exacte sans qu'ayant
champion du monde sur chacune des
dissidences exactement ça veut dire que
500 mètres mais ça veut pas dire que je
vais le champion on a toujours été en
recherche de ce titre le fait que ça
fait c'est pour ça qu'on le fait
maintenant ça risque de changer parce
que les olympiques
on n'a pas deux ouvreurs on est champion
olympique sur une distance puis on
recommence à zéro par la suite fait que
là on se demande si ça devient
intéressant de faire encore une fois un
titre de champion du monde
au cumulatif puisque c'est peu
représentatif de nos olympiques avec on
est là dedans ce moment avait qu'à voir
comment ça va se terminer mais pour
sauver air force il s'appelle qui
prennent les grosses décisions et que
c'est à voir si on va conserver ce titre
le ou non
ok c'est intéressant de constater dans
les sports amateurs
[Musique]
que les olympiques ont aussi grande
importance alors que c'est juste un bloc
de 4 en ce moment en natation il
international swimming league sont en
train d'avoir des procédures juridiques
contre la fina qui est l'instance qui
gouverne toute la natation donc les
championnats du monde et les olympiques
parce que tout ce qu'ils veulent faire
c'est de rendre la natation sport
professionnel faits que c'est d'avoir
des équipes avec des contre eux les
équipes engagées nageurs pur jus pour
manger pour eux puis les y aider des
ligues professionnelles avec des
sponsors et août et la finale ont fait
des démarches pour suspendre les nageurs
qui voulaient participer à cette ligue
là ouais pour exercer un monopole fait
toutes ces nageurs qui sont faites
menacé d'être suspendu son temps avant
de poursuivre le financement pour briser
cette espèce de monopole des
compétitions importantes
oui c'est tu t'entraînes pas pour une
fois chaque catheram samse c'est un peu
contre intuitive de penser c'est l'été
sam tout les sports toujours un sport
professionnel en lui mais les joueurs de
hockey
c'est à chaque année la coupe ce texte
entraîne à chaque année pour avoir une
chance de performer si tu passes à côté
de ta chance aux olympiques c'est long
80 de revenir mais ça arrive à plein de
monde
l'olympique soif de pau faire la
sélection olympique parce que ce dans
certains spas en patinage je sais pas
quand ça fonctionne les gars notation
c'est une journée oui c'est une
compétition tu vaux aux olympiques rupo
cette journée là où six malades cette
journée le de 70 ans 1,80 à vendre et
atteindre l'espèce de l'ancien giolti
une zone de tad d'ultimes célébration
dont sport trouve selon quand est ce
qu'on devrait élever les championnats du
monde de gros aux statuts des olympiques
parce que c'est le même niveau a tancé
tout les mêmes les meilleurs au monde
qui sont allés au tiff et que ça devrait
aussi prestigieux important c'est que
les olympiques ont vraiment réussi à
avoir le rebranding incroyable timide et
on se fait tous les athlètes se fond des
filets le rêve olympique depuis qu'il
était enfant petit système super bourrin
mais le monde de la réalité c'est tout
aussi prestigieux et oui mais c'est
quand même style de
deux camps c'est cette mentalité là on
aimerait ce thème nous c'est ce qu'on se
disait comme ça pas de bon sens tillon
petit moi je déteste les gens qui disent
que les athlètes ont chaud qui osent
enfin efficace comprenais pas comprenez
juste pas c'est quoi le tpiy cet athlète
tous nos potes shocking vous savez juste
pas caché que s'est passé dans sa
journée est juste pour les éléments
qu'on essaie juste pas le sport pour
exercer un athlète ne choquera jamais su
ce que les éléments qui seront peut-être
pas optimale cette journée l'autre fait
que on y décrit le pop rock et ça me
passe pas si c'est sûr ça repose pas
situation suppression dans le vécu pas
parce qu'un kodak aujourd'hui que
choquer même y en a tous les jours des
codecs savez combien je dire nous on est
allé à nos entraînements on va jusqu'à
mettre la musique on va jusqu'à mettre
des gens qui crient dans les estrades
pour une place effective jeunes
comprennent juste pas à quel point les
athlètes on est prêt à sauter fait que
c'est pas c'est ce mouvement ne devrait
même pas exister mais mais c'est sauf
que ça fait que essayer de casser cette
espèce de grosse engouement l'autre qui
les olympiques si parce que c'est un
combat qui passe même pas sont
possiblement perd même temps je
réfléchisse à en parlant à voix hautes
tantôt je me disais oh au final est-ce
que c'est pire que ceux d'avoir vraiment
c'est une enfant plein d'affaires qui
sont au même niveau mais une affaire qui
comme ocz de tueuse justement pour
donner le rêve un rêve de plus de rêves
de plus aux jeunes athlètes mais on
s'accroche à sauter c'est un peu le
joueur de kiel qui s'accroche à la ligue
nationale s'accroche pas nécessairement
à la coupe stanley mais s'accroche à la
ligue nationale nous on s'accroche aux
olympiques on s'accroche pas des
semaines médaille horrible bosses est
courant c'est fake
ça peut être mais après ça de participer
c'est une chose de pouvoir remporter le
ménage je pense que c'est aussi le titre
olympique mais c'est complètement il par
rapport à choquer dans les peco 6 et non
pas de choquer aux olympiques
il ya tellement d après la préparation
physique qui est cliente qui est un
travail acharné le jour après jour après
jour après avoir fait la préparation
mentale peut se
après tout ça y est tout le temps en
l'espèce d'un facteur 2 m en natation il
ya des épreuves que tu fais des
centaines des milliers de fois une
journée du plonge plus avant sont là
pour te fasses un temps x pissos pas de
spolier comme une espèce de facteurs mr
qui sait pas trop pourquoi cette journée
les séparent iv ou une journée du sort
les choses incroyables sylvie peut-être
ça s'explique d'une certaine manière
mais il est tellement de facteurs camani
ça devient difficile de tout contrôler
de tout expliquer ben oui pitié jeudi
des situations j'en ai véhicule puis je
me dis comment ça une fois j'ai réagi de
cette façon là une fois j'ai pas réagi
de cette façon le thé c'est complexe d
oui exactement
pourtant pitié pourtant on se dira je
suis stimuler de la même façon depuis
les douze dernières années est ce à dire
que je fais dit qu'au bout du monde
j'ai la même routine pour ma préparation
autant mental physique mais aussi parce
que je suis super routinière puis j'ai
joué pas changé mais comment je me
préparais pour moi toute l'équipe je
m'habille mon patin droit avant mon
gauche de toutes ses effectifs y ont
rien que changer le jeu tu es toujours
je fonctionnais toujours de la même
façon mais pourquoi l'eau c'est ça mais
il ya des choses qui me rentrait plus
dans tête où j'étais assise avant
d'embarquer sur la glace puis le joyeux
un enfant crypte le samoan d'espérer
motivé je me dis oh mon dieu un enfant
qui crie on s'en foutent et mêlée fois
stefan thiele obama des aspects des fois
tu peux pas contrôler que 6,6 et tout ça
à prendre en considération tout trouvé
ça difficile des fois mettons nos
athlètes canadiens qui vont aux
olympiques
on les aime les encourage on veut qu'ils
performent puis des fois on est un patin
qui performent pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on a respiré qui fit qui performent
taux est ce que ça a été quelque chose
que tu utilises il est pour toi ou
banques un oui on est heureux on est
extrêmement 12,4 et dur qui
puis pour des gens que j'ai à vous dire
qu'ils connaissent rien voici les
pratiques mais partant et puis vous
pensez de meilleur que moi mais le prix
du canada ce prix ou d'un excellente
athlète dans voici là je dis si tu es
meilleur que moi j'ai aucune difficulté
au fait que tu ne te prenne ma place le
mais j'en doute des gens d'être beaucoup
l'eau mais voici sérieux dans son salon
exactement alors je le dis en tout cas
voici le vrai mais oui c'est de celle du
manger des victimes mais après 2
j'ai une semi menaces de mort que 2014
ça m'a complètement je tempère d'un
dingo qu'on savait pas trop ce que qui
que les mêmes les gens dans mon équipe
on fait nos recherches parce qu'ils
avaient peur qu'ils soient à l'intérieur
du village parce qu'on a pas été capable
de le retracer et yuki sa photo de
profil facebook
on n'était pas capable de retracer fait
qu'on a connus par un peu que peut-être
cette personne est assise du village où
est ce que finalement ça a été super
bien géré et puis ça il n'y avait pas de
souci mais moi je me suis rendue compte
qu'elle est ça m'affecter énormément
d'intérêt autant quelqu'un qui me dit
des boîtes et bien on est fiers de toi
sa me valorise 01 que ça me faire dire
que je suis une merde ça me faisait ça
me tire lait complètement vers le beauty
et que fais quoi moi j'avais de la
misère des gens qui sont peut-être plus
sont moins sensibles si je pense que
certaines personnes qui sont peut-être
mieux outillés pour gérer ce genre de
commentaire là que ça les a fait que je
suis certaine que ça les affecte
mais ils sont meilleurs pour le gérer
faire abstraction pas taillé pis mais
moi ça me sans même chercher le plus
profond où je me dis mais comment tu
peux dire des choses comme ça betty
souvent c'est quelque chose aussi
extrême que ce ses programmes à peine
une personne
c'est quelqu'un qui les bras même moment
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est sain
d'esprit tu vois qu'un seul pour faire
comme un malade est pas bien non emule
petit aux en effet qu'on est un peu plus
tard à fleur de peau puis andres
effectif c'était ça a été difficile mais
mais c'est sur sa pression moi je savais
par contre que si j'avais de la misère
algérie fait que j'ai pris dix outils
nécessaires pour que plus jamais que ça
arrêté en mai mais moins et il ya déjà
des gens qui permettent des fois c'est
une fois la langue 7 fois ou demande toi
ça va vraiment c'est changer quelque
chose aux autres ce que tu me dises que
dans le fauve belge devrait peut-être
juste mettre fin à mes jours puis ça
serait mieux lotis par c'est vrai que ça
m'a aidé ou que je souhaitais que
c'était à cause d'une contre performance
à one annoncé pessimistes étaient des
gens rien à faire comme au lieu de chat
libye parce que c'est mon âge quand
j'étais en conflit avec mon entraîneur
avant 2014 fait que ça pour ce n'est pas
super bien puis la personne avait dû
sortir l'ue de chienlit pi2 auraient du
temps prenez plus fort plus torrides du
blabla fait-il des jo c'est comme même
tt seul aréna pour moi la moindre idée
de ce que de ce qu'ils parlent via votre
problème et ses beaux souvenirs voir à
l'aréna voir comment je m'entraîne tu
viendras cabré ça c'était comme dans le
fond tu es avoir des permanences comme
storage juste rester chez vous fait nous
dont jean comme une faveur qui fait
juste disparaît comme au pays on est là
on est là en plus c'est entre un poème
en vers une déception oui de ton côté
vie
les athlètes les athlètes d'excellence
comme ce style le plus dur jugé envers
toi mais oui c'était sûrement déjà super
super moche et comtois super dense et
toi par rapport à toi le pisa apprécié
tout comme l'impression de se voir un
petit rôle et qui est plus longtemps
encouragé puis le texan en plus de
cancers négative est fou mais pitié on
n'a pas besoin de l'appui de personnes
pour nos besoin d'aucun commentaire
externe pour se faire justice là on est
assez bon pour tout ce blanc au minimum
puis de se les rappeler nos mauvais coup
le 6 mai mais où est il ya des gens qui
pense quand même que ce sera nécessaire
les gens ce projet tant vous dire qu'ici
vous gagner mais c'est une victoire pour
les gens dans leur salon spa ton mec
j'ai l'impression que mes mails inverse
est aussi pressé de racheter on devrait
tellement célébrée tous les athlètes qui
sera la pause olympique pas pressé cette
journée là ça moins bien été je sais
c'est tellement un travail d'une vie qui
est il faut pas juger une personne sur
une journée de sa vie c'est un monsieur
est tantôt aucun dont on prend pour
acquis
nos athlètes le monde prenne sont assis
dans leur salon puis prennent pour
acquis que le canada depuis depuis 20
ans au patinage courte piste on est
médaillé sur toutes les épreuves mais on
est les meilleurs au monde il le monde
ils sont assis chez eux qu'ils prennent
pour acquis que alors mais là les et les
piques du père nos athlètes
on est bons puis ont regagné médailles
sont un peu des médailles c'est un échec
ouais non sont nombreux et médaille c
c'est décevant mais c'est loin d'être un
échec les tifs dit j'ai l'impression que
c'est sa peau pour redire ce qu'il
faisait dans tôt les gens comprennent
pas ce que ça prend pour se rendre le
fait qu'ils prennent pour acquis qu'on a
du monde qui se rendent là dessus mais
le monde se rende le jury donc pas leur
victime un serment aussi bien ne plus
être une autre décision là dessus oui
mais qui choque aussi ont suivi puis
c'est un peu le combat qu'on a je trouve
le sport amateur s'est construit
beaucoup à ce qui s'est fait
aux jeux précédents ou ou à ce qu'on va
dire parce qu'on n'est pas des sports
qui sont tes les visualiser où on a une
petite visibilité fait que ça fait que
on nous attrape un peu ici et l'homme
édition les gens qu'on est vraiment
temps de s'informer ou on nous voyait
des commencements l'aller les canadiens
on sait même pas s'ils vont en faire les
séries le thé mais on le sait parce
qu'on les voit tous os x 4 x 5 fois par
semaine joué c est qu on le sait que là
en ce moment ça va moins bien ou quand
ça va bien mais nous dansons en courte
piste d'un potager de sport amateur on
ne voit aux championnats du monde si on
est chanceux
pourquoi quatre ans avec l'asse comme on
se rappelle de hawaiki mal à gagner
locaux qui leur langue et leur charles
garnier l'os taxi tout le temps saut
mais en bout de ligne dans ces quatre
ans lui il patiente de jude law nous on
ne tombe et on s'est plantés pour ne pas
gagner toutes nos courses
mais ce qui en plus l'animateur va dire
où l'analyste ça va être
mariano remporté 90 médailles en coupe
du monde dans les délais quatre
dernières années fait que l'on s'attend
à ce que marianne hagen pascal [ __ ] 90
moi mais j'avais peut-être 3000 course
elle aussi là ça nous aide pas ça nous
aide pas fait qu'on a on a une grosse
pression
le pauvre justin 0 la pression déjà mais
je veux dire c'est qu'on a une grosse
pression de performant vous en épée
parce que ce qu'on rave party ce conte
relate comme fait si ça nous mais si je
te met sur un piédestal qu'on n'a pas
chouette retour en haïti
ça doit être extrêmement difficile à
gérer ce stress le de ces événements le
petit chapeau à votre préparateur mental
parce que pauvre et c'est ça doit être
ça fait tellement essentiel son travail
est essentiellement parce que c'est pour
vrai je peux même pas imaginer la
pression qu est-ce que c'est une course
la cause de ta vie tout l'investissement
de ta vie à un seul moment assez c est
inimaginable
ce goal à émane au stf habits nominoë ce
gala est magique parce que si on est
nous on était cinq athlètes filles 5 est
donc ces dix athlètes a jailli nous en
appétit
puis des athlètes qui ont pas les mêmes
besoins qui ont pas les mêmes enjeux
pile villes comme amsterdam puis c'est
ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils avaient une
stratégie pour qui chaque athlète est
différent pour nous tout
notre petit complexité dans un sens mais
lui savait tout y était prêt à tout qui
fait si c'est ça qui est complètement
foule lui vous suivez à l'année depuis
un peu d'enfants nous n'avez en uefa
bien on a toujours à préparateur mental
dans l'environnement mais vraiment avec
fabienne autres promis qu'ils étaient
vraiment engagés avec nous un peu avant
sotchi fait que goût de te dire 2012
il était et autour de l'équipe métier on
était on associer ton était on est un
peu là dans un sens à comprendre qu'on
avait besoin de recommencer
exactement mais là tu vois maintenant
c'est même sûr utiliser concrètement
comment ça fonctionne tout le
rencontriez juste le puits comment ça
fonctionne apparemment ça l'est pas ça
dépend si nous son rôle comme on était
très très chanson n'était privilégié
quand même le famille et à l'aréna dans
son bureau était à l'aréna
maurice-richard infecté fabié il
faudrait rendre une trentaine matin il y
aurait beaucoup dans l'aréna pittis pour
ça que sert ça en fait qu à mes yeux un
excellent des préparateurs mon père
c'est que l'habit prenez le temps de
nous observer de regarder qu'est ce
qu'on faisait pitié il ne connaissait
tellement bien que à la limite ils
savaient quelque chose clochait avec moi
par mon simple sourire ou monstres le
bon jour s'effectue maintenant bon matin
maria en baisse il faisait bon matin
mais ils savaient qu'ils avaient public
avait quelque chose ce texte comme au
dessus de minutes existait c'était soit
beaucoup de deux minutes dans une
semaine au caire ou à qui l'on va aller
prendre un café avec moi ça dépend tout
tati moi je pouvais pas rester dans
l'arena si on savait où on allait
prendre une marche où on allait prendre
un cas fictif est que chacun réalise est
d'une façon différente mais c'est ce qui
fait qu'ils étaient exceptionnelles du
virus est allé chercher tout le monde
qui on est tellement différents outils
moi je pensais aux gens avec qui je
patinais pas la personnalité de
personnes avec qui je patinais mais on
était tous comblés avec famille eksi
n'est pas assez fou puisqu'il ya
tellement de
moi j'ai tellement croiser des gens qui
auraient pu bénéficier d'un support
comme ça pique ça aurait changé leur
carrière littéralement littéralement pis
oh quand même que tu sois
dans le pot 2 % pour avoir accès à des
ressources comme celle là se rendent au
centre national ça nécessite
faut que tu fasses partie de l'élite de
l'élite de l'élite lives of duty combien
la nationale 10 en fait on s'entraînait
et développement donc on était quatorze
filles 14 groupes kings ce qui est
vraiment pas beaucoup de personnes qui
doivent cesser ces pourcentages vraiment
minime et pour te rendre le pour avoir
accès à sur pour avoir accès de
débloquer ton plein potentiel
c'est au début soit rendu leur est
tellement un tri qui se fait mais oui
par justement du monde qui prend le
relais
la capacité de se rendre l'homme et qui
ont juste pas les outils nécessaires est
ce que tu penses qu'ils aient beaucoup
de personnes qui auraient les toffes le
talent de se rendre aux olympiques par
exemple qui ont juste polis qui ont
juste pas le support que ça prendrait
pour débloquer cette espèce de 10,8 si
ça peut venir de tellement niveau de la
préparation mentale sony sont isolés où
le mineur je veux dire les parrains
l'environnement d'alors qui grandit
tellement de facteurs qui peut faire en
sorte que tu vaux petit il faut des lois
plus nombreux un potentiel c'est fou le
mail autre affaire c'est que je trouve
plus tard oui une belle ouverture mais
ici vous savez le conte être athlète
l'aude on devient super égocentrique et
on pense à noter que ça fait que ça
devient difficile de laisser entrer des
gens parce qu'on se dit si je me plante
je veux que ce soit de ma faute si je
réussis ben ça va être de ma faute si tu
y mets pas qu'on fait pas confiance et
au delà du sol au 6 mai c'est vraiment
parce qu'on veut tellement ramener saut
à nous parce qu'en même temps il y
aurait rien de pire que de se dire si
j'avais fait ça
puis des fois on a l'impression que ces
gens là vont nous bloquer qui vont pas
nous donner qu est ce qu on a besoin
elles aussi moi je trouve la belle
ouverture que les athlètes
on doit faire c'est qu'on doit se donner
la chance de laisser entrer des gens qui
vont nous aider à atteindre nos mii
vautier mais c'est tellement difficile
parce qu'on on veut c'est son nom veut
pas avoir d' excuses on veut pas avoir
d' excuse de ne pas voir performer de
pas avoir fait sien or fait ce fake mais
en même temps si tu le fais pour sap et
en devenir une aussi une excuse fait que
l eau je trouve là la langue qui est
mince pixi pas tout le monde qu'elle
goûte de preuves
coty vais pas ça peut être assez ça peut
être confortant d'avoir des excuses pour
quoi que
petit hic on cherche à perdre excusez
moi choses que c'est cela la différence
ceux qui ont des excuses ils reposaient
ce qui je suis convaincu je veux dire à
gimont aux gens dude gens tout le monde
mal oui je veux dire n'importe quoi je
dire on est toutes les pareil on fait
tout le 27 août mal aux jambes mais
pourquoi il y en a qui vont jusqu'à la
fin on a le même mal je m'occupe
beaucoup et à l'image plus lourde que
tout est fait que j'ai pas plus mal
peut-être mais il reste qu est ce qui
fait la différence entre toi + moi fait
la course que moi j'en ai pas d excuses
j'en changerai pas d' excuse toi tu
aimes soit 10,80 tomar peut-être
convaincre cas limites aussi parce que
je travaille plus fort que les autres
parfait l'ange pour ces gens là aiment
et on met donc encore trop de secondes à
nous autres
tu le vois ce que je te manger mal aux
épaules lui fait d'anata en auge
triomphé du col du à longueur de journée
de gratuité liste on est peut être le
sérieux qu'il faut regarder c'est un
métier tout le monde mal aux épaules
pourquoi tu étais pas pratiquer ce matin
j'étais fatigué tout le monde est
fatigué une sélection qui s'appelle
dallaire dans la force mentale me disent
que ça prend pour être un athlète
moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
qui joue l'autre 6 pour les athlètes
n'est sorti jeudi j'en avais l'os sur
l'équipement avec moi mais on n'avait
pas la même attitude ccd ya une
différence c'est ce qu'aime amman il
faut qu on a une différence parce que
comme je dis tout le monde fait
pratiquement les mêmes efforts c'est
quoi la différence entre une marianne
qui vont faire trois des jeux puis
mettons je sais pas une fille qui fait
exactement les mêmes joueurs qu'à moi
qui s'investit autant parce que je
dirais l'ol aussi le talent mais c'est
un fake il s'apprend différents ce qui
te porte et fait que moi je pense qu'il
est petit détail les défauts qu'on
remarque pickeu on pense qu'on a fait
mais finalement ça se joue à quelques
temps parce que ça serait juste pour ce
nom il serait tout c'est à dire c'est
pas fait pour tout le monde et ça cette
ville
exactement est ce que toi rapidement
dans ta vie mais ton juste d'en bas dans
des activités banales sur marquez danton
mindset qu'il y avait une différence en
toi puis les autres de de ton âge
mettons-le en termes de genre je trouve
que ce soit patins ou paul mais juste
dans ta dans la façon que tu approchait
des défis ou d'approché des des jeux qui
au final devenait peut-être plus des
jeux tant que ce n'est pas ce qui compte
vraiment un exemple moi je tiens quand
même à l'autre banc c'est ce qui arrive
ce qui est particulier spécial moi j'ai
pas l'impression que c'est pour ça qu'on
a pensé pendant très très longtemps que
je n'aurais jamais une carrière
moi j'ai dû apprendre à gagner
ok c'est lundi d'apprendre à gagner
parce que j'avais pas de regretter j'ai
un orgueil mais j'ai pas de d'orgueil
était meilleur que moi bravo je félicite
l'adversaire en sortant de la course
effectivement ça vraiment été basée sur
le plaisir et le fun que j'avais à les
montrer mes fesses mais j'ai jamais eu
d'excusés
comment une petite sacoche et du fun
c'est sur l'exercice qu'on en fait ben
je fais l'exercice je me suis jamais
posé de questions j'ai je fonçais j
allais petitesse outil fait que j'avais
quand même une rigueur puis une
discipline que j'ai tout temps eu mais
je peux te manquer ouais mais j'ai dû
apprendre à me manquer je faisais ça
j'avais dû j'avais du talent un juge
mais pourquoi je le faisais je pense pas
grave tu es s'abattre sur pie et que
j'ai du moins peut me sens prêt et puis
un peu plus savoir mettons et qu'est ce
que je voulais le témoin je veux tu être
une championne je veux pas être une
championne parce qu'en ce moment je fais
les choses pour être une championne mais
andré que j'y crois pas vraiment noté
fait que parce qu'en ce moment en train
de m'entraîner douze fois par semaine
ces gens là ils pensent à gagner mais
toi tu fais comme je gagne avec méthode
10 en termes de gammes hit voici comme
sérieux là tout le monde nous a dit je
dirais peut-être que la culture succès
risque de vol de bangui que c'est pour
toi c'était un pur plaisir de faire
s'exhibe y avoir une période assez
positive a fait son chemin la musi le
tpiy allez allez vers 6,6 et ses gants
ni ghonim et y était ultra négatif quand
tu pars à petit ça peut revenir en
bretagne aussi le tombeau changement
d'accord moi je pense que c'était
système a glissé mon attitude bien parce
que même à la fin même si je lai est une
championne on n'a pas changé sur six
était vraiment plus des prix compétitifs
sur glace changer un peu
comment je voyais les choses puis mon
énergie mais à l'externat glace tout cas
je sortais de la glace des mariannes sur
devient la peace and love à jouer parce
que tu peux pas avoir cette attitude de
l'autre c'est pas toi
combiné avec les fous parce que je
posais la question ce qu'on entend
souvent les histoires mettons un michael
phelps niveau olympique en 2000 il ya 15
ans et arrivent quatrièmes aux 200 fly
puis le pendant quatre ans n'en font de
s'investir ailleurs comme l'arctique qui
dit genre quatrième pleuvent
c'est un article super positif mais
juste en cercle et quatrième le
dissident 1,4 à dialoguer de 15 ans 1er
mai qui est le picom il est fauché par
thierry 4e puis comme par quatre as
crosby ça marche pour lui c'est comme
s'ils étaient dans tous les secteurs
tout le monde sait manière d'arriver à
destination
seppi peut-être que si toi tu avais eu
cette approche le n'arrêtait pas
fonctionné pour toi
pour lui ce témoin qui se trouvait qu
est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui fonctionne
exactement un ange mais moi je respect
et non pour ces gens là parce que c'est
tellement mon opposé jeudi comment tu
fais pour être grande et même ça n'a pas
de bon sens mais les outils vont
chercher leur force là dedans ils vont
chercher leurs motivations pis ça
fonctionne exactement les deux en fait
j'avais fait que le dénominateur commun
pour toi c'était juste éviter les
excuses puis même être responsable de
tes propres choix de tes propres
décisions puis de dire il y en a pas d
excuse moi je n'ai pas de regrets et je
pense que tout ça partait de je voulais
pas de regretter fait que je vais
toujours être certaine de donner mon 100
pour cent s'y attendre si longtemps que
mon 100 pour cent étaient sur la glace
puis que j'avais donné qu est ce que
j'avais à donner ben jawad fier que
j'avais pas avoir dit tu m'en irai pas
de regret honnêtement c'était vraiment
ça parce que si des fois une journée ton
sang pour ça c'est moins bon claveille
lit le lendemain ça va être mieux puis
mais il reste que si c'est ton 100% de
la journée c'est ton 100% de l'argent
mais si fait que comparé à toi - glace
que c'est ce que s'est comparé aux
autres bains ont fait un training de
pâmé mouche une fille deux pas des quais
c'est tough to le sofa beauté le monde
et puis non une composante physique qui
embarque pas ce que je dis refait la
chaise pendant musculation d'offres fait
que c'était pour me traîner mais comparé
à moi mais quand même je me suis quand
même allé chercher une fierté de faire
baptiser quoi j'ai donné ce que j'avais
à donner puis la journée c'est une bonne
journée
c'est quoi maintenant le fonds va entrer
plus spécifiquement ça m'intéresse
il a fallu la femme pour faire qui
écoute c'est la puissance aérobic
maximale puis le ton pour pour un
exemple de cette ce sera 15 fois sur une
moyenne des efforts des efforts de une
minute avec 30 secondes de repos 15 fois
des efforts maximums excès vraiment
rohff oui mais en partant c'est quoi
laisser coi le situe à peu près les
mêmes lensois samba sow
on veut pas aller et un trop long parce
qu'elle en fait
ça va dépendre le but c'est vraiment que
cette patate qui pompent le thé avec nos
jambes faut y voir une certaine douleur
mais on veut pas aller dans ne la parle
qui est complètement différent de thé et
qu'on veut pas aller chercher une mal de
gens m'ont gâché un coeur qui pompent
fait que maintenant ça va être soit un
des plus courts tour mais plus rapide où
ça va être des plus longs tôt mais moins
rapide parce que sinon et que
puissesseau 30 secondes de repos une
minute maximum une minute excipients
courte piste d'un fond nous ne peins 10e
à la natation il n'y a pas cet enjeu
mais maintenant nous pour qu'on a on se
lance aussitôt avec autant de briques et
commenté dans un tour lancé et que je te
dis qu'on a une minute de repos actif
mais c'est pas vraiment ça parce que tu
sais comme qui on parle au bo fait le
faucon en une minute de repos pour déjà
qu'on se lance pour qu'à une minute on
sera partis n'étaient pas des bonnes
journées assez de puissance
mes entraînements préféré ouais c'était
plus du spécifique 1000 à 4000 mètres
pour nous ces neuf trophées xi comme
moyen de coexistence moyenne 1 mm
vraiment rapide là ça va tourner autour
du 26 mai en ce moment le les bonnes
courses tournant une trentaine 29 que
c'est pas mal sont en ce moment
actis une minute et demie défendre mais
si la distance qui à la fois va vite
stratégique mais tu gardes ton gars
parce que ces neuf portant
un choix ça m'a passé mais fait le genre
d'entraînement qu'on faisait ce thème et
on a trois fois trois tours deux minutes
de repos c'était pas à bloc mais c'était
comme 90% tels tests sans mal mais c'est
le fun le titre dans le fond les
entraînements aérobic c'est le pam qui
te parle aussi du temps doux vélo parce
que le sait puissance à un allègement un
peu plus le commercialisent exprimé en
face parce qu'il ya un entraînement type
plus ton coeur un entraînement des plus
puissants parce que nous on avait quand
même comme j'ai dit une composante de
puissance mais il faut que je sois
capable dans le meilleur des mondes vont
être capables de s'offrir à 100% comme
500 est pas une bonne réalité mais on
veut quand même essayé de s'approcher
des trophées qu'on veut a vraiment
cherché une capacité musculaire puis on
ne le sprint ça va t'aider tour lancé et
fait d un retour le plus vite possible
le
et la question que je me pose par
rapport à au patinage de vitesse courte
piste même chose sensiblement avec
l'athlétisme
ouais
c'est maintenant aux 800 mètres course à
pied avec deux deux tours de 400 dont un
record du monde mais le record du monde
nikon
il est pas vraiment un enjeu quiconque
tard et dans une compétition
internationale parce que le monde se
paye cependant le dernier 200 c'est là
que ça explose fake mais ton temps
sprint dans notation tu t'entraînes pour
mettre 50 miles pudeur 23 secondes
s'entraîne pour le moment où est ce que
tu portes et a bloqué mais petit seul
petit feu le plus vite que tout peu
vertueux mais est-ce que l'entraînement
de sprint mettons pour 1 500 m est-ce
que c'est plus tant traîné à être
capable d'exploser après trop hautes
ourmes et on s'est un peu même en jeu
nous c'est devant un très bon départ
fait d'avoir un premier tour et demi qui
le plus vite possible
puis après c'est de maintenir on sait
très bien qu'on va perdre la vitesse
avec un enjeu aussi de technique mais
aussi tactique affecté moi c'est sûr on
va ajouter aussi la façon qu'on patine
sur la la la traque et qu'on va tous
acquis au début on voit souvent des
patients qui sont excessivement large
pour prendre le vitesse puis plus la
course vous en faites vont se terminer
ni on va avoir tendance à un peu
rapetisser notre tracé mais ça arrive
sur mes tongs du japon et enfin ça ça
doit arriver en fait m tu peux pas
partir juste à bloc phares comme c'est
notre seule ça aux 500 et 500c sur 500
tu penses aux adversaires jégou de te
dire
peut-être de retour deux tours et demi à
faire parce que maintenant ça va quand
même vite le dépendamment de qui est
derrière toile mais honnêtement au 520
des fonds pense même pas l'adversaire
parce que je sais que ça va pour se
dépenser comme ces quantités adversaires
pointent derrière toi mais pour vrai
c'est la seule différence comparable
absence pour des questions puis vraiment
le dans les derniers tours l'on va
peut-être plus penser où se situer sur
la trt active pour laisser le moins de
chances possibles qui perdent le moins
de vitesse mais pis
mettant à cette vitesse le chaque fois
je regarde une course maintenant un bloc
d'un match nage de vitesse courte piste
j'ai comme les les points même parce que
parce que juste pour avoir mieux joué au
hockey un petit peu dans ma vie puis
chez quand arrive à pleine vitesse sa
glace le tpiy tu peux juste lâché
l'adhérence moi je suis parti on le sait
quand et à bloc comme seuls 2 est ce que
tu penses à soho faut juste pas cheap
ans belotti pense pas et je veux dire on
ne veut pas ça arrive des fois qu'il y
en a qui font juste dans un virage
troupes mais c'est pas ça arrive
vraiment souvent en plus se médite pas
pensé à tout et on a tous des enjeux
dans mon sport respectif le titre parce
que ça fait j'imagine que tu dis que
c'est quoi la roque et fait que kiki
c'est un vrai petit feu y a pas d'erreur
des fois c'est la glace pense t-on pas
quoi des fois c'est des erreurs
techniques le moi je paye un bloc où je
me suis auto kick et la lame tydos
arrive là mais souvent puis souvent ici
absolument et qui s'est passé c'est
injuste blanche et ça doit être un
maximum et la qualité de la glace est
quand même par gare ce qui paraît une
compétition plus genre la glace oui août
et on a des très beaux stands en
amérique du nord
c'est parce que les glaçons et des pays
nordiques la cty ça se passe mais bon on
connaît ça
en europe de l'est en ce moment l'équipe
canadienne état est en bulgarie à sofia
pour le championnat du monde on s'entend
dessus que genre en bulgarie pas une
place oui qu'on a et ce tant sur la
glace au tibet je me rappelle on ya été
en 2010 piste elle à en faire l'outil
mais on n'a pas le choix at il faut
combiner avec exactement c'est aussi en
même temps on est un peu victimes de
notre monde un pays où justement on
t'aime tu plonges et revient de gascon
et un pull victimes dans ce sens-là fait
que soumah nous on essaie de recréer des
glaces témoin est belle en entraînement
public et ont gardé le même tracé
pendant tout l'entraînement si on voit
ici d'aller ce challenge est d'une
certaine façon parce qu'on a mené on
sait pas sur quelle place on va tomber
tiphaine viande paul choix et l'accès au
sport tas juste en temps réel à la glace
tout le temps - ci va se sentir ça tombe
dans les détails techniques du support
métier nous nos lames sont ajustés donc
on est décentré vers la gauche
on a un berceau une banane qui nous est
justement tourné cinq notre beauty une
touche la glace etc t on aux larmes ils
sont quand même et spécifique la maxime
et hongun glace par exemple minc est
plus molle donc on va avoir plus
tendance à rentrer dans la glace et que
l'on peut aller modifie un peu notre
banane notre berceau puis fessia
l'inversé la glace est vraiment dur mais
on va pour rentrer nécessairement fait
qu'on valait encore corriger encore une
fois notre banane pour pouvoir respecter
tout des petits points techniques qui
nous en fait que 1er journée qu'on
arrive sur une glace ben en fait comme
au hockey c'est une marque on a juste un
peu ou et que tissent en bout de ligne
on s'en sort quand même bien qu il était
passé de chacun des trois ont l'aspect
cité comme ce qui s'est exactement
exactement qu'on appelle des fois on
j'avais en compétition puis la piscine
le fonds était plus profond parce que le
lion le temps d'amasser tout seul
ouais mais avec standardise puis avant
aussi que tu arrives à haut niveau est
ce que de la chance de manger dans juste
des piscines standardisés paris dans des
piscines que le fond est plus loin et
bloquant des dépôts pour ton virage des
repères c'est pas les maladies ça change
quoi
mettons ça changera pas parce qu'au fond
au fond de la piscine de communiqu way
vecteur la ligne noire au fond qui dit
le milieu du couloir puis a feinté une
croix qui est à un mètre du mur quand tu
vois la croix tu commences à servir à
jeter dessus planifie ton virage mais
qu'un le veut le fonds est plus profond
la croix est plus profond avec la
perspective fait qu'ils arrivent plus
vite
1 enfin il faut que tu travailles tu es
repères pour être capable de tant aimé
tct virage comme du monde qu'est ce que
ce phénomène on m'a justement enfin 80
50 ça fait une grosse différence
quantité des épreuves plus longues comme
d'au moins un de ces détails le camp
pour moins de 5 ans et pas cru justement
aussi ça peut créer des emplois de
remoulins
ouais tu veux c lip sync et aux impôts
cru bien qu il ya une différence a
vraiment moins vite sous l'eau dans les
po cru avec 7 points creuse ouais ouais
puis mosquée sur la force fait que le
chou logeait la mesure qu'il n'y avait
pas de pur comme taille 50 cm en bas de
la surface mais quand tu pousses joueur
fait qu'en terme et on le le plancher
d'un an et demi à les 50 cm en beau
souvent les talons et touchés soit le
fond les talons leader tate celle foule
oui la température j'imagine
standardisés natation parce que tu es
aussi que les piscines que la
température
d'autres vont arranger dans 72 secondes
à cinq semaines pour le monde tu faisais
de la synchro excellent et une largeur
synchro il reste dans l'eau par la
commune quatre heures d'affilée fait
qu'il peut juste pas bien comme ça non
non c'est vraiment différent face notre
eau chaude le petit pramac issus deux
fois plus normal
oui si ça va pas contre mais quand même
pas 4 x 4 bouteilles d'eau de plus le
temps s'est comme pauvres qui boîte at
on nous a même fréquence que d'habitude
sauf que tu parles de l'eau deux fois
plus du tout non non non ça c'est plate
mais des fois il y as tu des
compétitions extérieures n'ont cependant
jamais j'avais un côté piscine et en mai
l'ong peace et en donnant tout petit jeu
de tout à fait la longue piste au début
des buts et j'ai effectué des sports
différents carrément passé des sports
différents mais c'est jusqu'au québec on
a pour les infos il ya un anneau me
quittait qui arrivent et qui encore
extérieur mais que par enfin tout les
moyens de pression on aura enfin un
anneau couvert à québec mais qui a été
jeudi c'était pas possible d'aller la
machine à tubes 5me lac saint-jean donc
on n'allait pas se taper trois heures de
route pour aller faire de son fils un
effectif on avait un peu cet enjeu
l'appui après ce bain honnêtement c'est
moins intéressant le faire de longues
pauses extérieur loti 15e - 49 à s'en
fou pour vrai lyon je lève mon chapeau
d'avoir fait ce fx a fait qu'amener mais
on peut au choix de s'exiler 800 -
calgary parce que c'est le centre
découvert qu'on au canada fait que les
coins non on ne peut on n'avait pas
cette chanson parce que ben si tu n'es
pas de québec
malheureusement puisque faisait pas
vraiment libre de l'outil mois l'ong
peace qu'un jouet aux olympiques le jeu
c'est avoir un oeil extérieur de à tout
les sports de cdn mais en fait on dirait
que c'est le sport c'est un des sports
qui a l'air le plus tough
que j'ai vu de ma vie tpiy jacquemetton
tout les sports sont vraiment difficiles
il y'a des sports plus technique on
espère que son plus haut dans la force
physique
le patinage de vitesse longue piste on
dirait que c'est
un des sports qui musculairement défonce
le plus affecté vois finir une épreuve
le les murs sont comment crampes ishaq
devant emmeline ces [ __ ] l'air
incroyablement s'inviter s'ajoute une
composante sont seuls ouais c'est se
sait pas comment tu fais ton contre la
montre contre la mort est magnifique il
faut non seulement que tu as dit que tu
challenge physiquement parce que il faut
petit pays c'est que ça va être du pain
mais en plus tu es tout seul parce que
non moi ça me fait capoter ça moi je
sais vraiment pas un sport qui me
passionne nos jours j'aurai jamais mais
vraiment c'est fou c'est fou avec quoi
non je suis pareil le score qu'est ce
que vous faites quand je pense que c'est
sur cd gurs aux grosses cuisses les 110
rue de l'hôtel dieu sait combien de
temps ça prince après unitaire de 400 m
il faut à peu près est un peu gelé le
nombre de tours je le dis pas par cas
mais 18 tout juste pour l'enfant pour
qu'il paye sur dix huit ou dix minutes
c'est débile hausse du stock pippa paul
la part du lion à bloc tout changea
corrida parce qu'il faut que ça soit un
jour car cet extérieur et intérieur avec
à chaque tour il faut que tu penses à
changer de ben ouais le plus flou
publicis touche en compte est
disqualifié j'aime faire du mal à
refaire je me dis non mais sont bons
s'ils sont traités
mais tant qu'on fait le parallèle avec
les 15 femmes internautes à sion mais
quinze 100 m c'est 60 longueurs en 25 m
c'est 60 longueurs pauvres hères le ccac
ce quinté groupes d'âge
à chaque compétition y en a un qui finit
de hub de langue arabe en or qui brille
c'est de l'orgueil les disqualifier août
au titre c'est ça arrive que le tabac à
maintenir le niveau olympique je pense
kil yon l'aide de l'entraîneur ou si le
tri qui ont un panneau
c'est arrivé en erreur c'est justement à
sotchi
un goût des pays bas c'est le meilleur
sur le point de gagner l'or olympique et
aux dîmes une main puis sont ici
s'apprête à changer corridor puis son
entraîneur il ya dix noms changent pas
pour changer fait qu'il ait dit ce
qu'elle fait parce que ça ne va pas
c'est qui on a fini ou non certains à
penser qu'ils avaient pas besoin de
changer d'avis avait perdu sa médaille
d'or à cause de son âge parce que lui
était il changer le système était
l'autre raison c'est un robinet il
savait très douces en haleine pour
vouloir d'excusés d'abord d'apporter
pour encourager et écouter tant que
d'encourager écouter ton coach pied des
sports m c'est pas bien vu le terme
étant que
et au scandale celui qui répond au coach
le sait hull kr au mal d'une tentative
d'acte été encouragés à propos cette
question fasse que le coach te dis ici
disent tu restes le jeu reste le même on
était un petit peu mais vous autres vous
avez de la prise des décisions
stratégiques pour sa part heureusement
mon entraîneur il est seulement d'un
côté de la patinoire
bakchich peut pas le regarder de l'autre
bon facticité de l'action qui se passe
si ce n'est qu'on n'était pas au courant
on était quand on va commencer à être
encourage et appuie trop regarder les
entraîneurs qui étaient là comme un
support puis on sait qu'ils sont là mais
dans nos courses de vraiment plus
prendre connaissance de notre
environnement puis de plus je jouais
avec ce qui se pense que avec
l'entraîneur c'est un trait de caractère
justement peut-être utilisé aussi tu es
les athlètes on est très égocentrique et
de poche watts et si ma performance
mon sommeil mon alimentation moi moi moi
parce que c'est pour être ce niveau le
tapage chouette
et pour commencer à donner de son temps
à gauche à droite outils de faire feu
recentrer de là dessus mais après ce
dans la vraie vie c'est pas comme ça que
ça fonctionne ce qui est ce qui était
évidemment il faut qu'ils soient
capables de prendre tes propres
décisions pièce mais je pense juste que
tu te fais confiance aux gens qui disent
quoi faraco à pipi il faut que à manier
peu juste pour toi tu es jeune allemand
- d'autres choses à taxer gros cas
manquer des 13 personnalités qui sont
encouragés dans certaines baies dans ce
port louis dans certains spas puis après
c'est fou comme s'ils réagissent à la
vraie vie parce que tout est reçue à un
ajustement comme ce afin qu'ils étaient
tu as des clash
oui puis séchée en cours de danse et
chant plein la bande à petit c'est super
sans vraiment désorientés parce que
vraiment une bulle le sport plus
longtemps et dans cette douleur je pense
que plus dur c'est après parce que parce
que c'est ça parce que tu t'enfonces
puis suivi dans cette bulle pendant
tellement longtemps que quand on sort de
ce fait comme mon dieu c'est sa réalité
qui c'est correct dans le sens que tu
sois dans le sens que c'est vraiment
correct et on est des athlètes on est on
est déroulé pour performer pis si c'est
correct que ça se fait de cette façon là
par contre c'est sûr que ça nous aide
pas après ça quand on en sort effectué
ce serait de trouver peut-être une façon
de faciliter un peu la tension en même
temps j'ai pas de piste je sais pas
comment on pourrait faire passer moi
j'étais une personne qui devait vivre
soit 100% parce que c'est quitte à 6,6
prend-on énergie à préparer ton ta
retraite des passants pour ces malades
d'heure parce que comme pour l'amener à
imaginer que ce qui peut fonctionner
c'est fake c'est correct qu'on le fasse
mais il faudrait que les fédérations et
comme un jour des services
d'accompagnement d'un pré retraite
je profite il y en a des services oui
avec le nsc l'institut national du parti
qu'on a ici au québec ici c'est vraiment
bien c'est juste que maintenant il faut
que tu ailles la chercher cette agglo
trémie malheureusement c'est pas tout le
monde qui fait t on et on a tendance à
vouloir c'est encore une fois ceux gérés
par nous-mêmes peu de dire que on va
être capable de passer au travers
puisque mais finalement on n'est pas
capable parce qu'on n'a jamais su
comment faire inspecter ses collègues
d'aller demander l'aide que justement se
faire encadrer encore une fois mais
encadré pour être capable de son cadre
et puis c'est tout de la chance d'avoir
un talent qui prône le naturel des
communications le dollar monte pas
problème avec ce puits
même chose pour roseline filion qui est
venu mais c'est pas la chance de tout le
monde s'entend pas que tout actuel qui
étaient contre il le fait d'être
athlètes-étudiants personnalités
publiques fait que ce qui fait qu'après
suscite à l'aise en communication peu
comme un peu resté dans fauteuils
publics
ouais mais pour d'autres qui est pro qui
sait pas une facilité le sait vraiment
comment ça zéro problème ou un piti
brands pour compléter ce que tu dis j'ai
l'impression que quand même même si
j'avais un à côté il est même si c'est
pas écrit dans le ciel où je m'envoie en
ce moment un pic je sais pas et où ma
ligne complètement il reste que j'avais
quand même besoin de passer par cette
phase qui était jean sombre et lugubre
c'est super important parce que si on
veut pas en ce que je pense c'est pour
te faire une fleur à toi en tant que
personne de john pays d'un aussi gros
que dire bits de vie et puis a pu
essayer de noyer soudan ok toute une
carrière
d'accord je vais m'épanouir c'est faux
ça va te rattraper sur l'eau peut-être
te rattraper dans cinq dix quinze serbes
peut-être fois j'en dise quand ça va te
rattraper fait c'est off c'est triste
ces genres un deuil temps à vivre
pourtant dans les faits le fils
entourent toit puis ou titouan et après
sa main tu fais toi le plaisir et le
bonheur de te connaître parce que
derrière ce masque de l'athlète une
personne cette personne moi je dis c'est
elle qui va accompagner jusqu'à la fin
des jours fait p le may est vraiment pas
évident de travail ces milliers d'offres
et douloureux c'est comme aïe aïe aïe
des mauvais jours encore une fois et on
n'a pas la reprise les bons mais en bout
de ligne je dire en ce moment dans une
période où je vais vraiment bien et
vraiment mieux je me dis je suis
vraiment content de l'avoir fait mais tu
me ramènes en octobre novembre doit
disparaître je pu être là là c'est sûr
mais c'était important que je le vis
tellement un grand bouleversement
complètement ta vie ton sociale
la chose par laquelle définit la chose
que ta vanne la valorisation et ceux
d'un coup disparaître mais je sais aussi
la chose que tu fais ok c'était très
chaud c'est trop de choses en même temps
qu'à ajuster tu le dis le cema routine
qu'il faut que je change complètement
mais j'ai pu de routine
moi je suis en même temps je peux pas
m'en donner une routine parce qu'il faut
que je vive cette non routier de l'autre
après ce que j'ai pu mais ami avec le
faut que je me refasse des amis mais des
amis que j'ai flanché pendant 12 ans
parce que je pouvais pas c'est comme si
toi là qui fleurit à saint félicien les
primaires ont reporté gens en même temps
le moyen vienne composantes connu fait
le même temps je l' ai je la refaire du
sport mais là tu en arrives dans le
sport on a des attentes sites des jeux
comme maintenant je fais quelque chose
que je suis vraiment pas bonne fait
qu'on peux tu me voir d'un oeil
différent puisque c'est dur aussi parce
qu'on veut que les gens te regardent en
tant que marianne la personne et non
l'athlète mon regard juste l'athlète
fixé comme je vois rien de me regarder
de même factice et plein d'enfants t'es
tout seul depuis personne avec toi
quittant cordes excitante plein
d'affaires qui arrivent en même temps
que au juste que tu laisses le temps
passer même si les gens ils sont comme
on est là pour toi on t'aime tu es ma
mère comme ça mais tu as l'impression
que personne qui comprend s'était dit
même si tu manges marvel laurent paris
disait mais bon si marrant j'ai pu
m'arrêter
j'entends que tu as aimé ce que tu as
fait pendant 30 ans j'ai j'entends tout
ça mais c'est tellement pour la mort
faire c'est fake ça prend des gens qui
ont vécu ce que tu as vécu ça prend 10
en six mois je me sens entouré d'anciens
athlètes de programmes de personnes je
savais qu elle qui avait vécu la même
chose que moi pis ça ça me faisait du
bien parce que les monsieur madame tout
le monde qui me disait si tu mets ma
propre famille qui me disaient qu'ils me
comprenez ça ne m'est d'impôts au
contraire j'ai eues j'étais un peu
repoussée parce que je me disais je vais
pas bien j'ai pas envie de
des dettes un fardeau dans votre vie en
ce moment parce que je suis vraiment
personne enjouée positif bien en ce
moment je peux sommet des pistes
laissées mode solo et en impute un mince
affaire les verse fait que messi soit
mais là ça ça vaut cela semble ridicule
ça se peut que ça me rattrape pas encore
l'autriche dans ma première en effet que
ma première année c'est sur sa lettre le
plus difficile mais je pense que ça va
encore me rattraper à certains endroits
c'est sur le sida dans trois ans les
prochains jeux je pense pas que vous
êtes un différend entre le 10 et ce jeu
mais particulier des chances soit le 4
mai si c'est pour le courtecuisse pas en
mieux parce que c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est mon bébé mais si c'est pour
autre chose aussi pourquoi pour fait que
mais moi je pense que mon expérience
maintenant mon aventure olympique il pas
terminée je pense que je vais vivre dans
votre jeu c'est certain moi je me
rappelle quand j'ai arrêté puis on a pas
compétition au même niveau le mais quand
j'ai arrêté de manger
je me me prenait à juste avoir des
habitudes
qui réfléchit des fois j'allais au jim
bien place de jaude faire de quoi pour
être en forme physique est en train de
faire là musculeux trop spécifique genre
au 50 m papillon
puis le jeu me dit tu es des deux
répétitions de chin up max le plus
misogyne qui se décide enfin de l'autre
côté lever à 7h pour aller fort 7000
mètres de natation parce que c'est la
seule chose que tu connais ta ville
le tranquillement ce ces partis mais là
dessus et surtout d'études émettons des
réflexes qui se faisait
juste pour acheter ce que c'était le
talent est au peps
quelques jours à les gens à aller à la
piscine pour mettre les tensions des
estrades j'allais vous qui n'a changé
des fois j'allais sur le bar la piscine
filoche parlé au coach parce que quel
point tu es habitude d'aller au ps est
prêt à lui ça fait ça faisait pauvreze
15,1 qu'à trois heures et demie j'étais
au peps 3h30 gère-t-on opep qui soulage
face à 3h30 dans mon horreur j'avais
rien d'autre c'est tout ce que je
comprends ça faisait aussi des fois oui
pis c'est ce qui est dur en ce moment
aussi c'est que mon corps échange c'est
[Musique]
quand même temps c'est normal parce que
tes seins c'est aussi une partie de moi
qu'il faut qu'il laisse aliments au
corps d'athlète parce que je suis une
athlète qui même si genzyme et auch
s'est entraîné comme jeu juste que vous
comprenez quelque chose que j'ai
beaucoup moins que les 30 ans a
maintenant encore ça
puis mon entraînement que je vais te
mons paraît trop spécifique je peux pas
ce produit
moi j'étais sur la glace deux fois par
jour 6 jours semaines déjà loué c'est
d'être entraînée quand une vie et
deuxièmement s'il faudrait il faudrait
que je marche un petit bonhomme pour
reproduire ses skis haut mais fessier
mais quad cc66 est aussi possible
j'ai même offert à tous les jours du
squat ne seront pas nécessaires et
attendues pour ramener le corps que
j'avais été fait et ce qu'il faut que je
laisse à l'ipp sochaux selon le chemin
du mollet et leur faut que je laisse
dans mon coin de saint justin
mais c'est long plus c'est grâce aussi
dur avec des quizz si ça rentre pas
dedans un peu de se laisser aller là de
faire comme qu'est ce que je fais pas
que j'allais au jim je me disais joue au
jim pour avoir mon corps viendront pas
ton corps fille fait que les lettres
google laisse les participants
correctement et que d'autres comme entre
eux
l'acoss et du service bus hybrides et
brosse pour un sport de retourner
bredouille c'est ce pourquoi tes photos
mais pas de quoi casser audi kolles spin
off c'est en fait ce qu on fait les
choses avec moi mettons nous d'accord
salut les prochains mois s'est ouvert 40
d'eau des transports juste de me quad on
agit pas de broc et que j'ai pas choisi
drop et parce que j'ai mal aux bruins
comme évidemment mon beau score et comme
à à 10 ou 15 août ans j'ai vu une vidéo
y allant chacun attestant qu'un au
revoir un peu ta préparation physique
pitt squat genre 250 livres le jeu pas
combien de rémi lacaze le corps est
tellement spécifique c'est fait on des
gens vont s'en rappeler toute leur ville
c'est exactement ce que j'avais mais
j'étais content vu l'autre jour là j'ai
fait j'ai eu un petit mot à la bouche
squat je faisais pas ça on était trop
fort pour faire ce qu'il fallait faire
du single ex quoi bon n'avez pas de quoi
vous êtes capables comprend et qu'on
jouait à une jambe puis en même temps
mais comme on est souvent sur une taie
sur une jambe
saint tite en hausse du cac et laser
avec le avec le poids de la borde le
font souvent
bordeaux était assez fort pour les
charges qu'on aurait pas eu et les
factures côté avec la barre à georgia
tech ont été un peu le pied sur
compliqué vu les gens facon faso et que
tu t'es juste avec ce jeu peut faire 120
kg avec et sur une jambe ou deux jambes
s'imagine commun que
ecti fait métier moi dans ma tête j'ai
juste se chiffre pas dans ma tête je me
disais oh j'aime toutes les gueules à
une jambe
oui quoi mais oui et épices espère
spécifique parce que pour une petite
note explosivité sortie mais il reste
que l'autre jour chez rogers y avait sur
la reprogrammation du single kiss et
comme homme mon dieu c'est j'en ai marre
j'en serais même pas capable de payer je
me surpris le marché
ok je me suis caché flèche sa mort être
au fait de ces deux hommes et le corse
où le corps ça rappelle tout le temps
c'est moi une mère exemple xavier
dernier politiques saluent dernier c'est
un joueur de hull trop longue distance
annotations puis
sa dernière année en fait il s'est
glissé blessé puis a fallu qu'il se
fasse opérer puis il ya eu trois mois
pour s'entraîner trop calme hors
s'entraîner pour le 32 km du lac saint
jean plus qui disait c'est tout le monde
et même si toi tu seras pas s'entraîner
plus que deux c'est mon corps j'ai déjà
fait tellement de fois je sais quoi qui
s'en vient mon corps va s'en rappeler
en quatre mois est arrivé deuxième de
est arrivé 5.5 secondes derrière le
premier nom puis c'était une course et
étoffe les vagues très très vite
mais son cas j'en ai rappelé ce moment
toute ta vie tu voyais vraiment meilleur
que la moyenne des gens ou quoi pour la
gazzetta villedieu
j'étais encore capable de faire si
c'était ce qu'on demande de fond celle
ci voit encore les en rappel non je suis
inquiète c'est ce que ceux qui les
créent ce fait ça peut rendre pousser à
être plus capable de marcher pendant des
combinaisons qu'on fait le trou l'autre
jour je me suis je vraiment défoncé les
jambes et les bras
je suis mon dieu mais il fonctionne
qu'est ce que je peux bouger aujourd'hui
rien n'est pas une semaine de vacances
dans une semaine dans ce sens bien
l'admettre mais rentrer c'est super but
de faire un peu de buzz bien d'accord
c'est possible on réserve un petit ému
se faire un peu de bruit
je t'invite à faire je suis une fois
dans ma vie et vient une fois le
lendemain les deux derniers les deux
jours après justement parce que j'étais
un lebron direct bayal déplier mes bras
parce que ce qu'on avait fait ce genre
max chinois
qu'il y avait des matches et 9 10 ans
qui n'a jamais fait je te donne y ait
des prémices au secours je peux
retourner
est ce parce qu'à la fin c'est que tu te
fais pas dit que ping son monde se
félicite éric martin
non c'est surtout l'esprit que ce point
est futile et open justement le top 6
avec avec meego je veux pas faire les
open nantes mais tu fais pas les watts
pour les femmes mon enfant oui non même
pas non même pas non parce que bâti à
manger où on s'entraîne
ils font un gros happening pendant les
open puis à chaque vendredi ben c'est
justement ils font des vagues qui se
fait que l'entraînement et comme
organiser différemment mais qui me
disait xavier collin pitau jeunechamp
morgan que votre juger ça lui a donné
que vendre et puis cette semaine je peux
pas encore fax a donné que sur cinq
semaines
un trou que je vois mais honnêtement
j'avais pas envie d de les faire partie
c'est ce que j'aime a coaché par manu
manuce une ancienne joueuse des
canadiennes de moyens que vestiaire des
vainqueurs
mais je veux un peu n'importe quand mais
je veux pas tant souvent parce que je
vois de jim parce que je suis comme à
moi savoir hier matin québec québec de
francs maria mai mais oui c'est le style
et vendredi manu puisque je m'entraînais
a vaincu avec moi j'espère fait je vois
deux fois samedi parce que justement les
chevilles comprendre la masse comme ça
ok je me sens oui puisque je me sens
très esthétique asthmatiques sommes
quasiment quatre fois mon cas deux fois
semaine un coffee depuis la jetée comme
dans le lot
sao paulo je vais pas je vais pas je
préfère j'ai un peu modifié et mon
entraînement mais mais ce manuel est
tellement que les fâcher comme manuel
non on s'en fout n'y a pas de stress tu
comprends pas aux gens comme moi ça fait
18 ans que je fais de la corruption
comme le chef est un sport parce que
j'aime ça je te dis pas que je vais
jamais le faire mais le star ni deux ni
moins bref le premier à méreau si je
peux tu juste faire commencer capable de
faire jean des bottes of light je
commence sa femme et de beaux lendemains
qui comme celle aux loges temps après de
rentrer là je peux pour certaines
j'ai en plus c'est pas vrai moi c'est le
6 mai 2e open défaite la partie
ces petites franchises et les boîtes de
foie qui fait une fois et on vendredi
et toi qui stratégiquement je pourrais
changer sociaux parce que tout ce qui
est un peu votre deux fois ouest deux
fois parce que justement le petit
agissent tu vois que tu peux faire de
mieux août a perdu ce tant pis si accro
site du clae vu que l'évocation du temps
différent c'est plus dur de voir ton
amélioration en mesure de faire vraiment
de stratégie parce que tu sais jamais
trop impacté avec le le téléphone le
seul à qui j'ai pris libres et clairs
mais le jeu devrait faire de refaire ce
pays aussi si maintenant j'ai fait mes
premiers ring la [ __ ] l'an passé parce
qu'il n'avait jamais fait depuis lors il
l'avait dans le wat à crocheter le bon
enfin que le ce et des pratiques et oui
fait que ça pousse à penser à l'autre
niveau
maintenant je fais face à moi comprendre
puis ça faisait dix ans que j'avais
profité comme le retrouve adulte petit
tout le monde veut dans les équipes
qu'elles sur tout les exercices avec
leur jeu comme ok je commence les gens
j'en fais une au mois de juin avec d'une
mise à me jeta membres qui veulent bien
qu'ils veulent faire la compétition fait
on dit ok puis j'ai fait ma première
officiellement en janvier avec la mère
de carla louise thibault a fait de son
financement pour aller au bout de
pelouse or en janvier puis le hammam ou
à l'opposé fille carol amar la matière
mais l'écrivain m'a dit j'aimerais alors
pour refuser ce sera la mère de carla
mais que j'ai vu ma première compétition
en janvier
ouais j'avais fait des compétitions
rapport a pour sa part les open mettra
dans une faute je suis là je me suis dit
je peux reprendre la compétition le cje
pour le fonio j'avais comme si je voyais
plus plaisir de la voyait juste comme la
performance et maintenant je peux
protège pas prêt il faut que je me donne
du temps là pour faire du shopping
quand il dit je suis skerla toutes les
exercices parce qu'il ya un poids de
base pour faire des rep isker ci dessus
et en dessous ce pôle et kaka sitafa de
port louis
edmée temps d'aimer mettons pas dit mot
[ __ ]
faire diversion au caire mettant les
compétitions trx qui mettons les
propylées vraiment toutes les exercices
le top niveau
je suis pas encore une preuve mais c'est
le fun parce que moi tu les deux je
m'entraînais par moi moi même si je
courais pour les enfants pilote c'est la
première fois que j'arrive au jam kg
jakovsky dia qui aujourd'hui ont fait ça
ça se passait comme guest comme cache t
comme quand je passe moi je ne souhaite
james a encore drainé j'aime ça j'aime
pas solides et danville factice je les
retrouvais ça pour soi même pas je
voulais pas me l'exigé à tous les jours
que je pense que j'ai quand même un
cheminement faire et je veux dire la
première fois de ma vie je savais faire
un bon rythme annuel
c'est comme ok alors vous allez vous
chercher des 10 et soudée 5 le pire on
était dans le vol qui commence le nom
j'ai regardé manu j'ai fait moi je
prends quoi
cinq des dix aidé comme je m'en fous je
commence je comprends pas comment moi en
ce moment
moi je sais comme marianne super saut
bas et j'y allais le chevet mais je sais
même pas comment de décider quel projet
allait prendre pour le warm up lors on
le prenait je mets les pieds dessus de
tout ça mais pour jean stretch et et
métissée commons était tellement
mécanisme qui était entré en criquets
cela il faut que on travaille sur fake
je le fais une fois par semaine avec
manu sinon je retombe tout le temps même
chaud le matin ouais ça le cours de
groupe à masnières 11h20 le vendredi
[Rires]
je travaille sur le fait que je suis une
personne complètement si ce que j'ai
mais parce qu au crossfit jeu tellement
nuls 10 bonnes affaires que chez perfect
lotus était ben j'ai cherché mon petit
matelas de sol pour que je recommence à
la basse et forêts nul c'est le fun est
nul parce qu'il ya place à
l'amélioration
oui quand tu es rendu au top niveau est
ce qu'un centième telle orientation
c'est sur six et dix centièmes s'est dit
ni enfant le sicom suppose d'être
capable de faire un mot [ __ ] high
capacity un match curieux à papa
l'entraînement qu'est ce que tu fais ces
jours ci qu'est ce que la côte occupe
tintin mais en fait j'ai vraiment eu
besoin d'un bris complant vraiment
typique des voyages j'ai voyagé
oui j'ai fait j'ai fait on est allé en
vacances en famille tout après les
championnats du monde en partie on est
parti à hawaï et notamment trois
semaines
toute ma famille ensemble au téléphone
c'était vraiment bien puis repartant
voyage backpack au mois de juin au
nicaragua c'est aussi en même temps je
parti dix jours
pas cool ouais jour je pense que ça
s'était bien ambiante et puis en même
temps j'ai jeté ma seule fin de faire un
peu backpack parce que j'avais jamais
fait ça de ma vie confesse un cadeau
mais c'était de l'équipe canada il y
avait jean c'était vraiment un autre
vraiment un autre type de voyage mais
c'était vraiment bien mais en même temps
ces sorties je savais que j'allais aller
dans l'immédiat puis voir tes où je
pouvais trouver ma place qui me situer
par rapport à ça mais j'étais vraiment
pas dans une bonne zone pour le parti
j'ai été chanceuse de téléphone toujours
sonné j'ai tout le temps eu des petits
trucs que je faisais puis ça me
permettait de impayés moncontour d'une
mise en forme et ça permet à 4 4
le besoin de travailler mais il reste je
pouvais quand même petit temps
permettait aussi oui sur le pays mais
combien aussi de rester un peu la
demande pu me ramener dans la zone ont
un peu mais j'avais besoin des crochets
et des trucs que j'ai eus que qu'on me
proposait que je t'aime tellement pas
bien avec moi que j'avais pas la
confiance que j'ai refusé des trucs mais
bekhti il fallait que je passe par là
qui plus est depuis début janvier j'ai
dit le on vaut mieux fait qu on va faire
ce qu'il faut pour se donner cette
chance avec encore une fois j'ai la même
mental pic j'avais dans le sport c'est à
dire et peut-être pas fait pour moi
c'est peut-être pour je dirais la job
mais sais-tu quoi fois les voir parce
que chante ça m'intéresse beaucoup ça
m'interpelle
puis je pense que j'ai une place
là-dedans fait qu'en ce moment je fais
tout ce que je peux sans savoir qu'est
ce qui m'attend mais je fais tout ce que
je peux pour mettre mes outils dans le
même team légion même panier puis aller
chercher le plus d'outils possible pour
que si une chance que ça fonctionne pas
c'est avoir fonctionné puisque ça
fonctionne pas je m'en dire belgique met
six ou sept voix c'est coutume à jane ma
tante douaouda 1 1 2 1 grosse création
soit dans le domaine des communications
mettant ses pas parce que c'est mon beau
jude 2019 je me projette pas j'ai
tellement envie de me projeter petits
mots ma vie est tellement calculée sur
quatre ans que je le savais tellement
d'avancé où j'allais à être en termes de
championnat du monde de compétition puis
de pec 2 médina jeudi je me laisse
surprendre fait que je prends les
actions que je peux prendre je vois où
ils sont mais tu aimais option mais je
me laisse surprendre parce que
je compte aussi peut-être que l'année
prochaine je dirais ouais je me vois là
mais pour l'instant je me laisse
vraiment surprendre parce que ça limite
ça vaut mais dès cette année de mettre
trop d'objectifs parce que je peux que
je prenne soin de moitié en premier mais
est ce qui m'attend pas ce que vous
retenez tout étudier dans quelque chose
parce que où qu'on va savoir je ne ferme
pas de porte à rien n'est vraiment pas
là en ce moment- comme l'immédiat c'est
aussi ta personnalité tu si haut si je
dois pas pu l'arrêter aussi pièce si on
parle de tout leur équation
je me disais si je retourne au sommet
des cols maintenant je pense que je me
tue parce que on va on vous pu me voir
pileux veut pose sa bôme aeby fait que
je me disais si j'allais chercher je
pense à mettre maintenant qu' un retour
aux études ou aller chercher quelque
chose ça peut se faire en même temps ci
mais ton oeil aux besoins et la façon si
ça a été très réfléchi parce que témoin
g2 sort un frère qui ont fait
l'université puis je dire je serais
vraiment aux mecs qu'on pouvait le faire
partie je me dis pourquoi pas le vivre
si c'est possible ou pas je vais pas le
vivre pour le vivre mais si ça devient
pertinent de le faire pourquoi poti et
que chaque session fac en ce moment je
pense que mon meilleur
ma meilleure option c'est de vivre le
jour le jour puis de voir c'est quoi
puis de prendre l'expérience que je peux
aller chercher et après ça allait me
perfectionner pas terrible c'est une
bonne façon de le faire surtout à ce
milieu là le c2
c'est d'apprendre en faisant moins en
fait c'est d'apprendre rencontrera un
autre un autre un autre j'aime ce sujet
- sagem plus sèches meilleur dans six
mois mais surtout de savoir après ceux
qui se forment vraiment ici c'est quand
même
c'est quand tu as quand même la chance
d'avoir des qualités en communication
comme on disait tout à l'heure parce que
moi j'ai des histoires de personnes qui
ont fini leur carrière qui s'ajuste pas
ce que tu lis pas tout le monde qui fait
du sport universitaire moi j'ai eu la
chance fait quand c'était fini j'avais
maîtrise c'est fait ou ne maîtrise
encore effective était pas
j'avais ce quand même mais c'est pas
tout le monde consulte une fois que ça
finit piteux pas nécessairement de
qualité hors du commun à part dans du
talent dans le support li na qui ont la
période noire longue un sacrement
quand tu vois paul boudreau progressive
un creux je veux tu travaillé qu'à
essayer quelque part toute ma vie dit
qu'est ce qu'elle va fort des fois tu
peux avoir désintérêt pour quelque chose
mais ça n'arrive pas aussi facilement
que selon suis aussi fait que je
comprends tout à fait en même temps est
un peu sorti je trouve que ma qualité
première c'est ma communication bronze
et je me dis voici le tpiy ça se peut
qu'en bout de ligne je finisse je ne
sais pas psychologue mais il reste que
je vois quand même communiqué en étant
psychologues des faits commis risques
vont exploiter sa pile va voir où ça
peut tourner puis ça se paie que
finalement c'est absolument implique que
c'était juste parce que tu en faisais
une fois par année le thème est sorti
mais pour l'instant ce que j'ai essayé
vraiment des enfers qui m'attire depuis
que j'aime faire et que tu veux mais ton
com comme contre derrière un tassement
en ce moment depuis déjà 20 quasiment
quasiment deux ans je fais des
chroniques à l'entrée principale rôle
vraiment axé sur le bien-être l'activité
physique puisque j'aime vraiment parce
que il ya un aspect de ces cinq minutes
dans ma chronique on il rêve
d'accueillir comme un peu il faut
vraiment que choix chaque petit piqué la
première chronique que j'ai fait a
maintenant je me suis vu évoluer les
gens m'ont conseillé par tichit super
bien pris en charge par l'équipe est
dynamique elles font défection j'aime
vraiment ça parlait de choses aussi que
j'aime le pi 2
les médiums la façon que moi je le vois
le sait c'est tellement une belle
fenêtre pour parler des choses faire
passer des messages type si je me suis
rendu compte aussi que ce que j'aimais
c'était pas nécessairement de me faire
dire à enfin la journée que genre ah
c'est beau ce que tout était belle à la
télé tout sens vraiment bien
by sa ça me rendait vide en dedans par
contre si à vous de me dire c'est
vraiment intéressant ce que te dis j'ai
vraiment appris ça me fait penser à ce
blabla
j'étais comme nice a le plus aidé une
personne tant mieux avec je me base
vraiment lathus j'utilise vraiment cette
fenêtre là pour faire passer dans même
temps le message qui essayait d'aider le
plus de gens possible tu y fais que ça
peut très bien se faire à la tv comme à
la radio avec la radio j'aime vraiment
sont aussi jetés avec une mission de
georges laraque d'ailleurs on a vu en
arrivant le matin georges effet
l'émission par après mais j'ai quand
même pu kasma faire un engin vu avec lui
or on le nez mais ouais c'est vraiment
cool c'est des petits projets comme ça
en ce moment si je parle beaucoup aussi
de de ma carrière de qu'est-ce que ça en
effet que je suis un peu j'ai encore le
rôle de l'interviewer 1 fois
mais laurence patinage courte piste on
pense à toi pas mal la pythie effectué
pas mal celle qu'on appelle c'est cool
tu es s'écoule en même tant pis je ne
cherche pas à m'éloigner de somme je
cherche pas non plus à effacer qu'est ce
que j'ai fait un petit potager même
extraordinaire et les gens sont
intéressés par c'est exactement ce que
j'ai j'ai envie aussi d'avoir un un
volet peut-être plus humain par rapport
à sauter fait que dans le sens que si on
est beaucoup axé sur les performances
axis ma carrière qu'est ce que j'ai fait
je pense qu'avec les amener avec le
temps ben moi je vais apporter une
portion plus mettons une menace au pis
ça va être moins des chiffres peut-être
moins sa voiture j'ai l'impression que
ça va m'amener ailleurs puis ça va être
plus intéressant c'est aussi mais comme
je dis je suis vraiment pas à m'éloigner
de tulle mais pour l'instant ce moment
ça que je fais le choix encore là dedans
puis mais j'aimerais m'en sortir je la
cite un métier qui me passionne
et puis je pense que c'est là dessus
qu'il faut que je focus parce que ce
e le pape s est une première passion
puis j'ai l'impression que je me trouve
une deuxième passion ouais ouais petite
élite
ça va toujours rester en tornade fait
d'essayer de ce dernier se veut pas
c'est complètement autre chose c'est un
expertise que personne d'autre acquérir
ce qui fait qu étant
personne n'est mieux placé que toi pour
parler de pâtes et de passage de tests
au quilit personnes qui me placer
quelqu'un qui le fait
mais ouais je connais encore le monde
dans qu'ils font qu'ils ont vu se
développer en tant qu'athlète fait que
je pense que tu fais bien de rester dans
le gers et dans le loop parce que je
vois ça j'ai dit oui parce que la venue
du coaching c'est quelque chose qui
vraiment pour l'instant non parce que
j'ai besoin de me détacher encore de
tout seul mais pilota faire ce que je
trouve qu'il ya en ce moment j'ai
tellement et je dis je dors est
évidemment tige
j'ai de la misère à dire oui à un club
sans savoir quand même temps ouais c'est
sûr que le dernier coup sûr mais je suis
pas grimper jusqu'à moitié factice si je
te dis que oui je veux m'impliquer puis
on va redéfinir leur rôle que je peux
avoir puis on va vraiment t on va vite
et se rhabiller définir tout ça puis
après ça on va être capable de dire ben
et mariama peux vous donner deux trop
soir samuel pisar être sorti de l'eau ce
moment je le sais pas comment je peux
t'offrir je sais pas où tu ici j'ai pas
envie de commencer quelque chose puis de
l'arrêter après fait que le public une
plage horaire non plus chose qui
pourrait que je trouve que en ce moment
je trouve un peu dans une zone point
d'interrogation puis en fait non pas une
réaction assez négatif jeudi dans une
zone exploratoire puis j'ai envie
d'explorer comme fautif et si je me mets
trop de choses - on dirait que ça enlève
l'exploration loti fait que le célibat a
laissé les choses arriver où c'est un
peu moins un peu mais que c'est correct
quand j'ai quand même certaines
organisations parce que j'aime souhaite
organiser l'aide en vie mais nous sommes
en lots faut que je surtout dans ce
milieu-là faut qu'on laisse place à osu
reprise bien c'est un dernier minutes
demain et que je dis pas non mais pour
l'instant
parce qu'un banal est nécessairement un
bon coach ont maintenant battu très
bonne copie non non ça aussi à les
comprendre
qu'est ce que je dis le c'est ce qui
avait suscité dans le sport - on nous
qualifie deux types de sportifs et les
techniciens
pioli chevaux way qui je pense qu'il
faut être technicien pour être un bon
aaron je pense que oui aussi parce que
moi je crois capable de bien expliquer
un jeune
comment pousser que sa jambe s'est mangé
le fil et à limite je me faisais pas de
questions j'allais le faire mais je vous
ai tout croche les déployer le plus
grand la plus grande puissance même si
c'était pas nécessairement la façon
optimale fait que ça fait que je suis à
la limite il ya peut-être des choses que
je n'ai jamais vraiment qu'on brise mais
je le faisais s'intitule exactement fait
que pour être un bon entraîneur j'ai
l'impression que ça s'apprend pas juste
mais ça prend une très bonne option un
technicien qui comprennent les
mouvements vont recevoir de bien les
expliquer c'était une belle
communication aussi le factice pour non
seulement un bon technicien qui est bon
en communication ne fait j'ai la
communication je pense que je peux aller
chercher les jeunes mais ça serait d'une
autre façon ouais je serai pas le head
coach le coach en chef de quelque chose
si je ne les portes y repasse el kiffan
tuneu ces explosions celle qui donnerait
une passion au point de vouloir
commencer de vouloir se donne tant que
je serai cherré l'eau je pense que je
pourrais je prêt à accompagner un club
est le sur la glace donner des conseils
parce que j'ai quand même bonnes bases
dans mon sport l'homme mais de l'eau à
être celle qui bat si des athlètes
d'immenses pour que je perde cette
personne me dit je suis d'accord avec ça
c'est une bonne façon de voir ça c'est
vrai puis même temps que je l'appelais
qu'à notre notre parcours à nous le tir
et vaisseaux s'il y en avait qui étaient
probablement cobourg et de nous deux
distingués dans ces deux catégories
vraiment j'étais plus technicien toit
puis tout est travaillé vraiment fois
king for même si ce n'est pas la façon
la plus efficace de le faire ouais c'est
je pense qu'il ya bathily
et ceux qui sont bons parce qu'il ya
intellectualise les choses il décortique
puritaine et d'autres sont juste
vraiment intuitif
la fonction permettant moment domaine
qui la musique il ya vraiment ce témoin
ce qui qui vont disparaître et
intellectuels là dedans qui vont
vraiment décortiquer les mouvements que
ces techniques ou petits l'apprentissage
de la musique et d'autres quittent leurs
ministres - dans les marais puis comme
ça marche c'est bien comme je fais
souvent en piste c'est bon ces deux
approches différentes et puis moi en
musique je suis plus le premier du
gorille plus intellectuel que intuitif
que chacun son approche
mais je pense une approche je pense
qu'il peut être plus favorable à être un
bon emploi mais tout est clairement tu
étais était prédestinée à ce sport le
parce que commencer quand même
relativement tard wade a commencé à 10
ans c'est une question que je voulais
poser est ce que par hasard au cea-leti
avec la voisine qui aie aie pitié
commencé à 10 ans moi j'ai commencé à 5
en danger le dit pitou parlement dans ce
coin là aussi
puis cinq six ans plus tard tu es dans
les meilleurs au canada depuis tes sur
l'équipe nationale c'est quand même
excessivement rapide factice mais sa
glace
fabre quelque chose qui se passe avec
elle non non attendez à l'oubli si je te
dis que j'ai pas un parcours normal
et puis les gens s'attendent à ce que
marraine est exceptionnel non moi je
sais ce que j'aime de mon histoire c'est
que les gens viennent me voir je pense
que c'est possible je commençais le
patin g11 en jeu comme un fils est
tellement possible et c'est pile est pas
un chiffre une personne laisse
absolument rien de dérouter de ce chemin
là si ce que tu veux le voyons donc
y'en a pas de chemin parfait j'ai patiné
avec une valve maltais qui a fait
exactement les mêmes jeux que moi le nom
pis alors commencé à 4 ans ouais ouais
j'ai commencé à dix on a le même
parcours et on a fait les mêmes jeux
d'échecs
ça veut on vit la même région factice et
il y en a pas deux il y en a pas de
solution vous êtes rentré à l'âge adulte
ces années le sait pas non plus
ces années-là change pas grand-chose à
n'émettons de 10
datant de 12 avril c'est le ton bagage
et accumule depuis que tu es si
nécessaire mais les années de 5 à 12
fois j'ai pas l'impression
moi je pense que tu gagnerais ben plus
mettons nos enfants les vannes aux
enfers légion
quand il est bien plus à faire une peine
de cinq à 12 tu l'as fait partie
premièrement ça fait qu cible c'est
l'fun pour aux hommes mais sait aussi
qu'il peut trouver
dans quoi sont vraiment bons t c'est
alexander popov sprinteur us
l'annulation qui dans son livre dense
nation sa biographie il ya une citation
de lui qui dit d alexander pope à viana
à tout les coins de rues ils font juste
pas ce dans quoi sont bons ouais mais si
tu fais tu tues tu destine les jeunes à
faire 15 part à cinq en tout 21 jours de
rock et parce que papa avec la ligue
nationale 25 buts ont jauni se rendre
aux olympiques dans un autre sport ça
ceux qui se rendront jamais même proche
de la ligue nationale parce que papa
helvètes ont donc il doit être bon mais
je pense qu'ils ont grévé vraiment fort
une panoplie de sports jusqu'à
aujourd'hui s'adapter ce qui nous
différencie t d comment ses intentions à
5 ans c'est le fun mais genre moi lancé
un ballon que j'ai été minable qui
n'osent pas me laisser ce qu'ils font du
cros suite il tape tape roth ou lieux
spécialisés dufresne à faire ce que
j'aime parce que justement c'est au lieu
d'être ultra spécialisés mai
mais ouais c'est ça toute ma vie
demander de faire n'importe quelle
grosse parka natation s'est jamais joué
au basket
toute ma vie c'est fou ça jamais joué au
basket ou dans les cordes des digues
n'ont une fois à 15h coûte 6 me avant de
déménager fait que j'avais même pas dix
ans j'ai dribblé une fois dans un cours
d'éducation physique
mendy au secondaire on n'avait pas coté
dit qu à court terme on n'avait pas la
chance d'expérimenter
oui il ya une question qui vous est
posée quand sûr quand je retourne à sa
fille
est ce que tout le monde le reconnaît
mais c'est un peu oui c'est ça tout le
monde est ici c'est tellement flatteur
smida mewes et c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est un peu le bon côté de venir d'une
région c'est que les gens ils sont super
fier pitié ils m'ont suivie depuis
j'étais tout petit j'ai fait mais je
quand même totti j'avais 19 ans fait
j'ai terminé à 28 sec pendant dix ans
pratiquement on me suivit si j'ai fait
la fierté le bcsa puis j'étais active
aussi dans le sens que j'ai tout le
temps été sur la map
j'ai des bons résultats
enfin quand tout le temps tout le temps
ça faisait que pendant dix ans j'ai des
gens m'ont vu ils m'ont entendu qu'ils
étaient fiers l'opus en même temps je
lis représente bien je pardonne à me
tirer déplore la méthode et représente
biais parce que j'ai une belle énergie
je sais rien je suis fier de parler de
ma région jamais fait l'objet que jamais
renier jamais en ôtant tout à fait je
peux le dire je le dis que j'ai dû lac
puis ces gens là m'ont porté le sait ce
que c'est mon porte et je reconnais sens
puis dans la rue giraud je prends le
temps aussi de parler aux gens avec
pepsi sonos je vois que du positif qui
est aimée majeur le centre créatif à
celui-ci s'appelle le centre créatif
marianne st gelais foule à renault et à
mon nom au fait
ils ont fait j'avais 25 un jeu mais ça
veut dire que dans l'histoire de ça fait
juste solidifier ta place dans le score
des bleus de ce sport le oui si oui je
me faire connaître mais en même temps
c'est c'est vraiment une fierté puis les
gens ils sont pas des petits pas
pantoute le ccm club si c'est parfois
aussi le type pendant dix ans maintenant
on me féliciter parce que quand je n'ai
au lac jallet tellement posthume en
cause et compétition c'est un fils
station parce qu'il avait théorisée
autorise le top là maintenant on pose la
question comment tu veux qu est ce qui
se passe où on va devoir prochainement
ti fait que si c'est beaucoup sopi c'est
avant tout être au pij pas gêné de me
promener puis je pense jamais non plus
de 6 à quelle force quelle belle une
belle proximité avec 6 avec avec ces
gens l'eau parce que justement on est un
peu nos amis pour nous on se serre les
coudes si on est fier des ph le
david beckham a big mac est une chance
qui me l'a dit parce que j'avais force
est grave c'est une vieille guerre de
tous les grands parrains ichn on oui
parce que moi par contre j'aime j'aime
qu'on dise que j'aide simplicité parce
que si mes temps tu me dis là ça change
pas mais si maintenant tu me dis à vide
robert vente viendra berlin et brême
tous ses sauts ça me dérange comme on
dit dans la vidéo je vais annoncer fille
si grave
mais moi c'est plus équipés de ces cris
la berbère parce que le métal est à
roberval parce que le talent est là on
n'avait pas de sages femmes chez nous la
mère robert dahlgren la fiction était
comme si rendu la sélection c'est comme
en mai mais oui ce genre en chine et où
jeunes et à l'hôpital robert fois la
chambre 4 mai - roberval 110 x cousquer
soir le cheylas imprime wifi quand on
sort pareil
mais j'ai juste en fait qu un combi
refus du fer qui a hébergé le premier
village qu'orange j'oublie le nom le ça
m'échappe mais avec toutes les affiches
des personnalités connues ou journée au
lac saint jean
c'est sur la maine le pis toi tu es là
quand tu vends pour l'acteur et les
pancartes des personnalités connues du
la visite watts et l'autre découle c'est
un beau projet en fait je partage ma
pancarte avec françois louis tremblay
aussi qui est impatient de vitesses
l'allemand way c'est un beau projet car
ils ont demandé de faire sauter je me
dis mais c'est bien c'est petit c'est
son appréciation mais je me dis c'est
bien qu'on connaisse les jets de chez
nous qu'on soit fier d'eux
le parcours pitié autant qu'on
reconnaisse l'athlète oui mais si les
électeurs le musicien et disc c'est ce
qu'ils font ce qui est vraiment digne
je parle de ma région parce que c'est
chez nous métier tellement des idées les
boues talent qui sort des fois de deux
régions plus éloignées plus pis tout cas
ça fait rêver c'est si c'est pas vrai
défonce met des barrières parce qu'on
n'a pas grand sens parce qu'on a pas
d'infrastructures parce que oui
j'encourage à ce que oui on en a et des
infrastructures tout mais ce que je veux
dire c'est ne pas répéter si tu as
quelque chose qui brûle en dedans toi
puissance un chipset fait addénergie
cette famille ça te fait rêver foncé
l'espace et petit détail la tête arrêtée
dans un sens avec mauss quand je vois ça
c'est beaucoup c'est je suis fier de la
petite fille qui ont osé puis fier de la
petite fille est partie de sa maison à
17 ans qui s'était amené à montréal qui
est laissé sa famille ses amis tu fais
un petit trio thé parce que je me dis tu
legault dit le faire tu t'es accroché à
ce sans savoir ce qui l'attendait c'est
en juillet que j'arrête médaille
olympique le registre les bretons qui a
encore moins de les faire les jeux à
vancouver pas quitter tout ça c'est si
c'est plus souhaité qu'en moi je me vois
puis les gens parlent je vois mon r'n'b
comme monde justice ça me ramène le
parcours ça me ramène l'aurait bravo
je me dis dumazy je commence à 4 c'est
exceptionnel sur ce parfait mot de la
fin je te jure au moins dix trucs masse
alors delgado départ déjà les athlètes
dans la vie puis le long des barres être
à la merci beaucoup
[Musique]